[Musique]
un bon soir le journal de tv soixante
dix huit pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale bienvenue dans cette
édition nous sommes le mardi 10 novembre
voici les titres la grève aujourd'hui
dans le primaire et le secondaire
plusieurs syndicats d'enseignants
dénoncent un protocole sanitaire
insuffisant dans les établissements non
content des dernières annonces du
gouvernement concernant les lycées
certains élèves étaient également
mobilisés invités sacha halgand du
syndicat lycéen de la fidl
alors que deux laboratoires annoncent
des résultats prometteurs pour un vaccin
contre le coc ville 19 des solutions
plus local émerge aussi à fontenay le
fleury
une entreprise a conçu deux machines
capables d'éliminer le virus dans une
pièce ou sur de petits objets découverte
et puis le dry fait son retour dans le
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines malgré le
confinement vous pouvez continuer à
emprunter ou rendre des documents à la
veille des commémorations du 11-novembre
focus également sur mémoire d'homme
c'est une application pour connaître et
se souvenir des poilus morts pour la
france
[Musique]
plusieurs syndicats d'enseignants
appelaient à la grève ce mardi dans le
primaire et le secondaire en cause les
protocoles sanitaires jugé insuffisant
dans les établissements dans une
bataille de chiffres autour de cette
mobilisation l'éducation nationale
annonce un peu à plus de 10% de
grévistes dans le secondaire - 2 9 %
dans le primaire
côté syndicats en avance 20 % de
grévistes en moyenne 45% au collège et à
mantes-la-jolie une délégation de
parents d'élèves et de professeurs ont
été reçus par le sous-préfet astrid
berges et ils sont venus exprimer leur
colère et leur ras-le-bol face aux
incohérences autour du nouveau protocole
sanitaire enseignants retraités de
l'éducation nationale ou encore parents
d'élèves ils étaient près de 40 devant
la sous-préfecture de mantes-la-jolie ce
mardi alors qu'une délégation était
reçue par le sous préfet le constat
c'est que chacun se débrouille avec les
moyens du bord et ça ça me pose un vrai
problème parce que on connaît la
pandémie depuis le mois de mars et que à
mon sens toutes les mesures depuis
confinement elles sont au coup par coup
dans l'urgence et il n'ya pas
d'anticipation sur la gestion du temps
scolaire en tant que maman d'élève
on demande à ce qu'il y ait une
réorganisation des espaces des lieux les
travaux nécessaires pour qu'il y ait
suffisamment de sanitaires pour le
lavage des mains des masques
gratuit pour les enfants les parents
d'élèves souhaitent surtout le maintien
de l'école au quotidien pour les
professeurs malgré les nouveaux
protocoles peu de changements sont
visibles hier j'étais dans une petite
salle de la halle et 40 mètres carrés
maximum et
j'ai jamais une classe à 29 élèves voilà
donc tous entassés des élèves de 3e des
costauds un des grands et à peine la
possibilité de circuler
l'heure suivante les élèves partaient
dans une salle de physique en salle
spécifique et c'est un 2002 classe un
regroupement de deux classes qui venait
dans la salle où j'étais donc voilà le
brassage il est là une situation à
laquelle tous souhaitent mettre un terme
et enseigner dans de meilleures
conditions
pendant l'entretien le sous préfet
semble avoir écouté attentivement la
délégation il a dit qu'il ferait
remonter ces informations
et pour continuer de parler de cette
actualité je suis avec sacha halgand bon
soir par téléphone pour toi
la président du syndicat lycéen de la
fidl vous êtes élève de première au
lycée saint-exupéry de mantes-la-jolie
alors depuis la rentrée les lycéens sont
mobilisés pour dénoncer lé protocole
sanitaire dans les lycées le hashtag
notamment en balance ton protocole a été
vue dès la semaine dernière sur les
réseaux sociaux et vous étiez aussi
mobilisés aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
cette journée de grève nationale est ce
que le moment était suivi d'ailleurs par
de nombreux lycéens dans les yvelines et
en ile de france
effectivement le moment aujourd'hui les
suivis par un bon nombre de lycéens il
va surtout pas beaucoup de professeurs
qui ont été grévistes aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de les faire surtout qu'ils
ressentent aucune boîte de souvenirs les
les corps professoral qui langeait tous
les jours et qui prennent le risque de
d'affronter le virus chaque jour est
pour nous enseigner donc on leur héros
devra alors concernant les lycées
justement le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer recettes
exprimées il ya quelques jours elle a
fait des annonces annulation des
épreuves communes du baccalauréat qui
sont remplacés par le contrôle continu
on va en parler juste après mais d'abord
je voulais vous faire réagir sur la mise
en place d'un enseignement d'hybrides
ans dans les lycées 50% de cours en
présentiel 50% en distanti lcd mesure
qui sont pas suffisantes le protocole
est pas suffisant pour vous quelques
tics en ciel qu'il est pas comme on
pourrait le penser un parvis de
conférence parce que le professeur ne
peut pas faire du courant
visioconférence est entré dans six
villes aux élèves les maisons qui est
pas applicable dans l'état du transfo
lire aujourd'hui
par exemple un lien je peux vous citer
comment ça se passe comment sais tu pas
dans mon établissement aujourd'hui
bailly les élèves dont 6,2 des devoirs à
faire chez eux il est franc 16e et puis
faut prendre les professeurs donc on
prend un retard pas possible c'est pour
ça qu'un allègement aussi qu'ils
demandent et des programmes mais bon le
ministère semble semble le faire toutes
oreilles sur le court les cours ont
distance yale je crois que votre
syndicat dit que ça peut aussi creusé
les inégalités c'est ça aujourd'hui on
le sait ça fait répéter pendant le
confinement à des fennecs n'ont pas les
outils numériques pour est au courant
dit en ciel et sur les les classes soupe
comme ça c'était pendant le confinement
pour bon nombre de lycéens de france
ce que non on reproche au gouvernement
c'est qu'ils ont pas les choses en place
et ils ont pas très les dispositions qui
permettaient à ce que ces élèves
puissent suivre un reflet manger type 2
sont là et du fait qu'on reproche au
gouvernement quelles sont les solutions
vous proposer tout en maintenant ce
protocole en trouvant le juste équilibre
on va dire pour que oui les protocoles
soient soient respectés et qu'elles sont
quelques thèmes quelles peuvent être les
plus les solutions les solutions je
pense qu on est sur un dédoublement des
je pense que le gouvernement d'approuver
le majeur qui est beaucoup plus forte
que si je devrais aller jusqu'à dire
qu'il faut fermer cet établissement
scolaire je peux y aller et je me
tordais plus sur cette piste-là que
qu'une autre je pense qu'on la joue du
delta qui sont beaucoup trop importants
par rapport aux risques que l'on peut
prendre à 168 pardon excusez moi
quatre navires us est énorme j'étais
proche de ma part qui sont en
réanimation de titres hospitalisés et un
bailleur proviseur de l'établissement
qui est hospitalisé c'est des choses qui
sont plus tenables déjà rythme qui est
trop effréné
les cours continuent comme si de rien
n'était alors que la beauté bayadh et
des gens autour de nous et on balade
éducation qui suit pas de traitement en
fait pour le corps enseignant le corps
professoral qui sont en danger
aujourd'hui et il faut que le ministre
et le ministère léger coûter près les
positions
alors concernant le bac je disais les
épreuves communes sont sont annulées et
remplacées par du contrôle continu
est ce que c'est de nature à vous
inquiéter d'autant que ce contrôle
continu pourra se faire notamment en
partie
distance alors qui fatiguent ans dans
les geôles et les conditions telles
quelles alors là on est vraiment à
quelque chose qui va pas faire quoi
parce que c'est en fait que ce système
là il va être démontée dès la fin de
manière que on pourra pas effectuer des
rénovations à distance de simplement
parce que la tricherie tra beaucoup trop
simple et le réel suivi pédagogique
pourra peut être assurée pense que ça
fait prouvé pendant confinement le bas
d'un contrat continue enfin j'ai fait un
flou papou stream autour de tout ça de
toutes les maisons d'armes s'est
d'ailleurs des médecins de montagne
aussi sur la présentation des syndicats
de la tpe de la était de la fsu ni de
bien de la cipel je pense qu'il ya vraie
d'un réfugié pardon excusez moi rentre
le ministère de l'éducation nationale et
les et les syndicats c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'il faut régler il ya un
dialogue est rompu pour arranger ça
parce que j'ai pas possible que des
mesures soient prises sans que quand la
passion qu'il soit prévu lundi car on
fait qu'on ferme et sasha 9 ans qui
était avec nous par téléphone merci
président du syndicat lycéen de la fidl
et élève de première au lycée
saint-exupéry 7 à mantes la jolie
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité quatre
mineurs placés en garde à vue à
elancourt ils sont entendus par les
forces de police suite à la violente
rixe de samedi dernier au parc des
coudrais un adolescent de 15 ans avait
été poignardé au thorax sont des jeunes
ce sont ces jeunes à leur initiative qui
se sont rendus à la police pour
s'expliquer sur les circonstances de
l'incident
il assure en avoir fait que se défendre
lors de cette bagarre les premiers
éléments de l'enquète parle d'un
affrontement sous fond de rivalités
entre bandes rivales de quartier élan
courtois la victime a été opérée à
l'hôpital percy de clamart mais toujours
plongé dans le coma séjour ne séjournent
sont toujours en danger
l'actualité c'est aussi le co vie de 19
avec cet espoir autour d'un possible
vaccin il hier les laboratoires pfizer
et bio ntech ontanon c'est un candidat
vaccin qui est est efficace à 90% une
ultime phase de test est en ce moment en
cours
en attendant d'en savoir plus des
solutions à plus local émergent pour
nous aider aussi à contrer ce virus dont
une innovation médine yvelines à l'aîné
du côté de fontenay-le-fleury une
entreprise a conçu deux machines tueuse
du virus la première dans une pièce
entière est la seconde pour deux petits
objets découverte avec bixente maria
santisteva une machine tueuse de
courrendlin virus c'est le projet mise
au point par cette entreprise de
fontenay le fleury
elle a choisi de chercher des solutions
pour aider à lutter contre l'épidémie de
lakovic 19 en mettant son activité
première de côté les deux machines qui
ont été créés la première c'est la lampe
peut y restons qui a été conçu pour
pouvoir nettoyer de faire pour à
désinfecter des pièces par exemple une
salle de réunion et un cabinet de
médecin une salle d'école qui utilisent
des des néons ubc qui viennent bombardé
entièrement toute la pièce
la deuxième machine elle a été créée au
cours d'une rencontre on proposait notre
lampe à un opticien qui nous exprimer
son besoin lui de pouvoir d infecter des
petits objets on a créé lui les boks qui
est un boîtier de 18 qui permet de
pouvoir d infecté en 30 secondes
les objets qui sont placés dans la
technologie utilisée à la diffusion de
rayons uv c à manier avec précaution car
potentiellement dangereux pour l'homme à
forte exposition les us et son efficace
contre tous qui va contenir de l'adn
les virus les bactéries n'est ce pas en
et champignons on a une dizaine d'années
de d'études médicales qui ont été menées
sur différents germes pour déterminer
les doses nécessaires pour désactiver tu
es différent pathogènes pour l'instant
une dizaine de la cuvée storm ainsi que
5 v boks ont été assemblés au sein même
de l'entreprise
elle souhaite prioriser la production
sur le territoire donc c'est important
de pouvoir travailler le plus possible
localement d'avoir le plus possible de
la production et de la recherche et de
l'ingénierie qui est fait ici
l'entreprise travaille actuellement sur
un troisième produit adapté aux
particuliers notamment les ménages avec
enfants mais ces machines ne sont pas
des solutions miracles et doivent être
utilisés en complément des principaux
gestes barrière elle est régulièrement
saturé aux heures de pointe et causent
de gros bouchons sur l'autoroute a13 la
sortie numéro 7 va faire l'objet de
modifications décision validée lors du
dernier conseil à départementale des
yvelines est la bretelle qui permet de
rejoindre la départementale 113 en
direction de poitiers ou d'orgeval va
être dédoublé un aménagement complété
par la réalisation d'une nouvelle boucle
pour se rendre vers le centre ville de
poissy et un rond point à l'entrée de
villennes-sur-seine un dossier élaboré
avec la société des autoroutes
paris-normandie coup d'envoi des travaux
espérée en 2025 pour une mise en oeuvre
en 2026 coût total estimé à 14 millions
d'euros
d'après les données de plusieurs
opérateurs les français se déplacent
deux à trois fois plus que lors du
premier confinement adea déplacement qui
se font notamment voiture et
contrairement au printemps les contrôles
techniques des véhicules continue vous
devez être donc en être en règle
pourtant aller à centres agréés constate
une baisse d'activité en cause le manque
d'information regardez ce sujet
d'eléonore sinoquet de patrick jacques
de dixmude c'est l'anniversaire la moins
de novembre donc voilà je ne
donc y'a pas de quoi je pense qu'il est
ce un délai non je n'ai entendu aucune
information là-dessus donc je suppose et
que c'était comme d'habitude des
interrogations des suppositions du flou
en résumé c'est bien ce qui préoccupe
les centres de contrôle technique en ce
moment pendant le premier confinement la
règle était clair les véhicules qui
devait passer cet examen de contrôle
avaient droit à un report pour le 2ème
confinement le contrôle technique doit
obligatoirement être fait dans les temps
on s'aperçoit que l'ensemble des centres
sont relativement peu fréquentées
parce que les clients sont peu informés
le l'information du contrôle technique
qui est considéré comme un commerce est
essentielle a du mal à passer
parce qu'il ya trop de choses qui se
passent quand on était au confinement de
printemps 2020 alors c'était très
différent parce que les centres même
s'il pouvait rester ouverts vous pouvez
pas garantir la sécurité de leurs
salariés leurs clients parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas ils n'avaient pas tous les
équipements qu'il fallait aujourd'hui
c'est le cas gants masques barrière en
plexiglas ou encore des infections de la
salle d'accueil le centres autovision de
bois d'arcy a mis en place un protocole
sanitaire renforcée
il favorise également les prises de
rendez vous en ligne ou par internet
au jour d'aujourd'hui le client il est
obligé de venir sous peine de
d'une amende de 135 euros la seule
précaution qu'il faut prendre c'est de
venir avec une détestation de
déplacement dérogatoires où on coche la
case 2 qui est commerce essentielles ou
encore la cage 7 qui est convocation
qu'on se rende dans un service public et
le contrôle technique est un service
public malgré tout une baisse d'activité
conséquente se fait sentir chez les
professionnels du contrôle technique
guillaume clavel la sueur d'ici peu il
devra recourir au chômage partiel pour
une partie de ses équipes au moins 20%
ce lancement en période de confinement
prévue pour le 20 novembre prochain
c'est l'application chopine ce cas il
s'agit d'un marché virtuel avec
l'ensemble des commerçants des douze
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
l'objectif pouvoir proposer en ligne les
produits des commerces basé dans
l'agglomération pour ce faire la
start-up commercer a été choisi pour
développer cette solution
écoutez ses explications recueillies par
nicolas landry
c'est mettre à disposition des
commerçants une application qui est une
application gratuite pour eux et qui va
permettre en principe de les aider dans
la période actuelle
elle permet pour les clients d'avoir
dans leur poche l'ensemble des dirait
des commerces de saint quentin et pour
les commerces et être en contact
effectivement d'être une boutique en
ligne en quelque sorte et être en
contact avec leurs avec leurs clients
depuis samedi dernier saint quentin en
yvelines a décidé de rouvrir ses
médiathèques uniquement en drive ce
service permet d'assurer une continuité
pour les adhérents et cependant le
confinement les précisions avec ce sujet
de célia 400 go les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines doivent
s'adapter face à ce deuxième confinement
comme pour le premier un service de
drive s'est mise en place depuis samedi
7 novembre les adhérents vont sur
internet pour réserver en ligne jusqu'à
cinq documents par carte
puis ils viennent les récupérer
directement à la médiathèque de leur
choix on a réussi à conserver le système
de réservation volante d'une médiathèque
à l'autre ces terres que un adhérent
peut faire sa réservation sur un
document du canal ou d'anatole france et
le faire venir ici au 7 mars
alors à partir de là comme d'habitude
quand leur soit on envoie
mais les adhérents viennent nous
chercher sur les heures d'ouverture la
médiathèque 17 marée et l'encours est
ouverte en drive le jeudi de 15 heures à
18 heures et le samedi de 10h à 12h et
de 15h à 18h livres dvd ou encore cédé
vous pouvez très bien venir chercher des
documents comme en rapporter une fois
rendu les emprunts seront mises en
quarantaine pendant trois jours ce
service de drive permettent à la
médiathèque de maintenir son bon
fonctionnement
c'est bien pratique surtout en période
de confinement quoi pour moi c'est
primordial à la bibliothèque c'est mon
lieu de récréation si je peux dire bon
je préfère y aller évidemment pour
choisir moi-même mais là qu'on ait pu
avoir cette possibilité là de rhj
loisirs des ouvrages afin peu importe là
je suis venu voir chercher un dvd en
plus en rendez vous même si c'est à des
créneaux restreint et sébire certaines
médiathèque s'organise sur rendez-vous
comme celle du canal à montigny le
bretonneux ou du château à plaisir dans
ce cas il faudra réserver un créneau
horaire par téléphone ou dans la
rubrique agenda de l'aïs médiathèque
simone veil rosa parks ou encore thomas
pesquet voici comment pourrait être
baptisée prochainement la nouvelle école
des eaux du moulin à villepreux dans
l'ordre l'astronaute la femme politique
est la figure de la lutte contre la
ségrégation raciale sont arrivés en tête
d'une consultation citoyenne lancée dans
la commune pour donner un nom à cet
établissement qui ouvrira ses portes en
janvier prochain le nom les eaux du
moulin a été placé lui en quatrième
position 1700 personnes ont voté par
internet par courrier et également par
mail du 5 au 18 octobre est les quatre
noms seront départagés par un vote lors
du conseil municipal de villepreux la
séance est programmée le 16 novembre
prochain
et demain mercredi ce sera le 102ème
anniversaire des commémorations de
l'armistice de 1918 qui mit fin à la
première guerre mondiale
pour ce 11 novembre beaucoup de
célébrations seront à huis clos à suivre
en ligne crise sanitaire oblige
mais si vous souhaitez vous plonger dans
l'histoire d'ea poilus morts pour la
france il existe une application c'est
mémoire d'homme qui a été créée en 2016
une
manière de transmettre la mémoire mais
aussi de sauver les sépultures de ses
soldats interview express avec le
concours de mélanie poké alors
l'application mémoire d'homme c'est une
application qui est téléchargeable sur
tablettes et smartphones que le souvenir
français a mis au point pour
géolocaliser les tombes de morts pour la
france dans les cimetières communaux
on s'est rendu compte que la tombe ça
pouvait vraiment être un lieu de mémoire
une sorte de voyage mémorial de
proximité pour les pour les scolaires du
village pour pour les villageois autour
même et qu'en fait la tombe c'est
vraiment le croisement de trois mémoires
c'est à la fois une mémoire familiale
une mémoire locale donc enraciné dans le
territoire et en même temps une mémoire
nationale puisque le mort pour la france
est mort pour la france ou milieu droit
là d'une guerre qui voit là un pacte et
tout le pays
le souvenir français notre mission c'est
vraiment les morts pour la france donc
ceux qui ont eu la mention qui a été
créée en 1915 que quand vous téléchargez
l'application de vous êtes dans le
cimetière vous vous retrouvez sur google
leur faim et à l'emplacement de chaque
tombes de soldats morts pour la france
devait une petite cocarde tricolore et
vous cliquez dessus et quand vous
cliquez dessus vous avez la fiche
matricule du soldat vous avez une
biographie d'une vingtaine de lignes
plus ou moins dans son fonction de la
densité de salies et vous avez quelques
photos donc ça avoir un vrai travail
d'historiens qui a été menée surtout
pour les soldats de la grande guerre
j'ai vraiment un travail de dentelle
chaque délégué général d'eau chaque
président de comité local du souvenir
français va avoir le maire et essaye de
le convaincre
en général les maires sont assez
convaincu et je dois dire que les
yvelines c'est vraiment un département
très important pour nous parce que sur
les 26 cimetière qui sont actuellement
sur l'application des lacs hammam 8 qui
sont dans le département des yvelines
est appuyé avant de vous laisser le
départ a été donné depuis les sables
d'olonne dimanche dernier la 9e édition
du vendée globe bat son plein et parmi
les 33 kts skippers en lice le
rambolitains louis burton sur bureau
vallée 2 3e participation pour lui après
sa septième place en 2016 2017 au
dernier pointage et à l'heure où je vous
parle 18h22 il est 25e au large de la
péninsule ibérique louis burton qui
avait franchi la ligne de départ
quelques secondes trop tôt s'est vu
infliger une pénalité de cinq heures par
les organisateurs à louis burton a
adopté une nouvelle stratégie celle de
mettre le cap à l'ouest
écoutez ses explications
[Musique]
filer vers l'ouest fait aussi vers
l'ouest parce que il ya trop avancé il
est un peu fort mais ensuite qui permet
de nous positionner
[Musique]
bien pour la suite avec une dépression
qui se baladent fait du yo-yo pour
l'instant entre les canaries et les
açores
j'ai envie de parier que
elle va rester un petit peu dans l'est
et j'aimerais bien passer à son ouest
voilà pourquoi on fait route vers
le vendée globe sur nommé l'everest des
mers va conduire les skippers dans un
tour du monde à la voile qui va durer
environ trois mois
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité l'information locale
revient en direct jeudi à 18h et c'est
avec mélanie poquet et belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]